there are some other celebrities that
have gotten themselves in a bit of
trouble Felicity and Laurie Lachlan any
advice to them what would you offer them
lots of advice
so in hi our prison consultant that's
one be open with people they are
celebrities people know them from TV TV
it's a big deal in prison
people watch it non-stop so they're
gonna be interesting what it was like to
be on a TV show you know what's it like
to you know may married to John Stamos
well yeah you know on TV what are all
these things like they're gonna want to
know they're interested I think if they
share their their stories and their
tales of woe and all that that they will
be just fine and I also think you know
it's important to listen to listen to
every other woman's story because
everybody there just wants to tell their
own story and be heard I think that's
what I learn most everybody's there
because of some you know crazy nonsense
and stupid mistakes that we make and
their attorney said don't say anything
you can't talk no we're not gonna put
you on the stand no no no and now look
they're in prison and they still are
just trying to tell their story
[Music]